what is up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 6 of 3d game
programming in Java unfortunately had to
rerecord this episode because halfway
through actually 80% through rendering
it my screen recorder crashed and yeah
unfortunately that footage is gone so
yeah this is a rerecord so if you go
I've tried to reset the code as good as
I could so if there's something that
wasn't there last time let me know but
it should be should be good I think this
is it's probably where we left off ok
yeah so um I've actually had a very busy
day and I am quite busy today so this
will be like a short episode it'll still
be pretty good but it'll be like a short
episode where I just want to talk about
a few things and demonstrate a few of
the other possibilities with this and
also is it I like it because the last
the last few episodes have been pretty
long
I think episode 4 or something would
like just over 20 minutes like is that
okay with you guys or would you guys
like what would would would you guys
prefer for me to have like shorter like
5 to 10 minute episodes where I sort of
add less code I guess and talk a bit
more in depth at um on how it works and
stuff like that or do you guys want like
a long 20 minute episodes where we
accomplished a lot drop a comment let me
know also if you have any questions
regarding like your thing not working or
problems please don't post a comment
because the YouTube comments really hard
to reply to and stuff like that doesn't
really show you the thread so if you if
you do want to ask me a question like a
long question with pasting code into the
comments tweet at me my Twitter link
will be in the description of the video
ok follow me on Twitter and and tweet at
me that's the best way honestly okay
let's get started because I've talked
for about two minutes without actually
doing anything first thing I thought I
wanted to talk about is Oh actually uh
we sort of last time I said that this
was a temporary fix because the the
thing that I have what will happen
unfortunately is if we um and it's by
the way limiting this what will happen
is if we are
where it need this cleaning up the code
if we change we sort of change this to
like no 720p 1280 by 720 then you know
it's will have to we'll have to sort of
come in here as well and change this let
me just live change this for you guys so
you can see the difference you know
you'll have to change this to 720 and
1280 and you'll see it now yeah
and that'll get really annoying because
you have to change the two places and
eventually you know you'll get lost
especially if you have a lot more code
around this so um it's pretty easy to
fix let me just roll all this down I
guess okay first thing well basically
what we want is we want to set this
value to the value of this to the value
of this sorry and this value the value
of this variable and the way we do that
is we need to create an object out of
this display class and read this
variable it's public so it can be read
yeah so let's go ahead and make a
private display will call it display and
this is creating an object of our class
will have to import it it's creating an
object of this display glass and go
ahead and go display dot height and over
here display dot width and if we change
that to
1280 by 720 then it should yep it should
work perfectly
so yeah that's er this is my little like
I guess fix that we've just done and
yeah the other thing I wanted to talk
about is sort of performance and stuff
like that because first of all okay let
me just drop this resolution down to 800
by 600 okay so at the moment and by the
way if you click twice on this then
it'll actually maximize minimize it so
yeah double click and it will maximize
itself for you um yeah so if we increase
this to like out on our 500 or something
you can see it sort of begins to lag and
it's this is sort of I guess a a lesson
on smart coding here what we can do is
instead of actually having to do this
entire thing twice we could just sort of
do this thing twice and it's hard to
explain so let's okay 500 is two and a
half times 200 isn't it so if we just
simply add that to I instead of adding
happy to do this again you can see that
with that we get the same result it
looks exactly the same except it's not
lagging and of course that'll work for
higher sort of things too if I if I
delete this again and we go to like 1000
or something you know 1000 is 10 times
is 5 times 10 times 100 but five times
200 so if we times is by five look at
that exact same thing except it's not
lagging so with lag and stuff like and
with with all because a lot of pitch a
lot of people seem to have issues with
performance and salvajes it's sort of
sort of smart coding in a way so yeah I
can't it's not it's not something that
you can really teach but it's something
that you sort of pick up up pick
you sort of you get used to it and you
start to be able to see things that in
some cases you know you'll be like oh
hang on a second it's going to be a lot
easier it's going to be a lot better if
I do it this way why don't I try to try
and do it this way and you'll see the
difference now we can't actually see the
difference right now because we have we
don't have an FPS counter and we'll
probably add that in tomorrow I don't
have time right now it's going to be
quite a long tutorial because there's
about 50 lines of code to add and about
20 minutes of explaining to do maybe
about 10 to 15 minutes of explaining to
do so yeah that'll be hopefully episode
7 tomorrow or episode 8 if we don't have
time to do it tomorrow
yeah and I also wanted to add one more
thing and that is alpha support or bit
masking as probably called in Java and
basically what we want to do is we want
to say okay if if we don't want to
render anything don't render it like if
there's nothing to render don't bother
rendering and the way we do that is
let's just make a variable called alpha
and we're going to set that variable to
this because that'll sort of be it will
just I you don't really need to call
this alpha but I've just called it that
it's it's not technically what's giving
it the alpha support it's it's just I've
just named it that because I can't think
of anything else at the moment but
basically where we're putting the
rendering into alpha we should probably
call this R and R or something but I
don't know we've got other stuffs it's
called render and I don't want to
confuse it with that and we can go if if
alpha is greater than zero so in other
words if we want to render something
then render let me just put that yep
so Randa um now that will probably have
before yeah that'll have issues on our
performance but first we can see it's
sort of um you can see the difference if
I shave it yeah so to do with
performance we might just drop this to
100 and try that
okay that's a bit better maybe even we
can just put this down
well dollar sign I just resume that
again so yeah um yeah so that's that's
alpha support um so basically it's I
guess it's self-explanatory um you know
if if alpha is greater than zero then
render it um if we switch this then you
know it's gonna sort of do the opposite
but what I mean is I I guess it actually
sort of say this you can say that it's
sort of rendering the opposite if we
switch signs it's kind of hard to see
but if you if you do it on your computer
then you can sort of see how it sort of
it flips I don't know it's really hard
to say um yeah I never mind um try it on
your computer you should be following
along anyway also the source code for
for all of these things will be in the
description of the video there'll be a
link where you can actually read the
source code because a lot of people
aren't copying correctly or something's
gone going wrong they don't know what's
what's going wrong so don't worry
that'll be in the description and yeah
so you'll be able to be able to have
your source code so yeah that's that's
probably about it it's been a bit of a
quick tutorial on our but we did a few
important things we talked about
performance we fixed a nice we fixed a
bug I guess it's not really a blog but
it's we moved on from a temporary fix to
a permanent fix and we also added added
a bit masking support which is very
important for the future if we want to
have transparency and stuff like that
yeah so I'll see you guys later
and uh yeah bye
you